[Musique]
on a suivi Emmanuel Macron en
déplacement à la Fashion Week au marché
de Rungis avec un manteau brodé à son
nom on a assisté à un point
philosophique qui a pas trop retenu
l'attention du Président
[Musique]
on s'en bat les couilles on s'en bat les
couilles la députée Rachel Keka félicité
le président pour son implication ou pas
donc là il est venu ça tombe bien qu'il
est venu voilà il a vu comment les gens
travaillent lui-même il a vu se lever
trop déjà nous-mêmes c'est pas facile
effectivement ça doit pas être facile
est-ce qu'on peut voir ce que faisait
président au même moment
et peut-être que pour Emmanuel Macron ça
allait mais pour d'autres le réveil
matinal était un peu plus compliqué le
patrimoine de ceux qui n'en n'ont pas
été préservé
non nous ne voulons pas taxer davantage
aussi son modèle social qui passe
d'abord parler d'éducation à la santé et
puis surtout c'est la reconnaissance
construire votre avenir de construire ce
vide votre famille le travail doit
continuer de mieux mieux être rémunérés
on va continuer d'avoir le prendre des
nouvelles du mec qui est en train de
bâiller
[Musique]
moi je crois qu'il a fait un AVC là
c'est tout pour les aventures d'Emmanuel
Macron à Rungis
là bien sûr très bien le monsieur c'est
vrai que non c'est c'est il est allé
hein
mais moi j'ai plein de j'ai plein de
potes là-bas qui m'ont dit c'est ils
sont pas très contents qu'ils soient
venus à Rungis c'est Nicolas
regardez on a comparé les mêmes
chiracles
pourquoi pourquoi les empêcherait dans
l'ensemble les gens savent que oui il
faut travailler un peu plus longtemps la
seule façon la seule moyen pour s'en
sortir c'est de travailler c'est de
faire des efforts on peut pas s'en
sortir autrement si on a plus d'heures
travaillées dans le pays pour créer plus
de richesses vous réindustrialiser
davantage le pays et mon idée c'est
qu'il faut continuer à soutenir le
travail mais moi ma principale
préoccupation c'est de démontrer que
c'est par le travail qu'on construit la
force d'une nation c'est une valeur
qu'on a tous
[Applaudissements]